[Music]
you smell a diamond last long makin
peace be with you I am Eddie your host
you are watching the Dean show every
week same time same channel this week
women in Islam liberated subjugated
what's up with the women in Islam you
got them behind this veil and what kind
of rights do they have you want to know
these things and you've come to the
right place and you're gonna learn all
we ask is that you have an open heart
and open mind and we're going to teach
you are you willing and learn I'm sure
you are cuz you're here we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
this is the theme this is the thing
[Music]
Salaam aleikum peace be unto you around
the love rockets how are you sir how are
you brother good good thank God thank
God everything is good I'm I'm did Allah
Allah the Creator is most kind most
merciful and he's hooked us up so glad
to have met you
absolutely and I'm glad you're here in
the destroyed women yes
in Islam and the people want to know is
the woman in Islam subjugated is she
oppressed or she truly liberated what do
you got to say I would say that Islam in
the middle of 7th century by the
blessing of allah subhanaw taala
had protected honoured gave rise to
women that today in the west and any
country that you choose women do not
have similar rights like the muslim
woman had in the middle of 7th century
now someone says come on now
this is fairytale stuff you know we see
these women there behind the veil you
know our women over here they can wear
what they want bikini top in the middle
of the street your women are over here
you got them in these loose-fitting
clothes with the veil on top what is
this we live in back four or five
hundred years ago what kind of freedom
is this islam honored the woman and the
creator of a woman that is allah
subhanaw taala had honored women so much
that their value as human beings is up
to their own character up to the old man
as a manners is what we call in islam
religion religion is you noble manners
so let's say for marriage for example
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
that a woman is pursued for marriage for
four reasons her money her beauty her
social status and her manners that's her
Deen think about a full woman standpoint
you can be born very beautiful or not
you can be born into money or not you
can be born to a family with high social
status or the lowest social status you
have absolutely no control of that what
is the only element that you don't
control of you character your Deen your
manners and that's the measuring stick
in Islam slam when the woman is covered
only her face in her hand is being made
as a human being with value not an
object for desire not a min a
materialistic way but a human being that
her care
and her stance and her education and her
courtesy is what matters if you look at
Virgin Mary and most of the pictures
that our Christian Brothers have even
though it's forbidden Islam to have of
the to depict of any holy messenger or
character by picture but if you look at
the picture whatever that dress the
Virgin Mary you see in all the pictures
that is the Muslim woman dress code yeah
why if you don't got nothing against
that then why is it bothering you that
this woman instead of wearing less she
wants to wear more absolutely and then
you get people that actually object to
that at the same time people pierce
their skins mutilate their bodies with
tattoos and piercing and dyeing their
hair different colors and doing all
horrible things that actually if it was
a disease they would be running the
doctor to cure the skins form and that's
freedom of style or fashion and so and
so forth for a woman naturally to
protect her honor and beauty and and and
self to the one who would be deserving
of it that's the husband then that's a
problem I mean obviously convoluted
logic the same time the honor that Islam
gave to the woman a woman not to be
touched and list to a man that is
deserving of her that a man that would
give her the title of a wife not a
sexual partner or whatever title
mistress or girlfriend that they have
and man would be responsible for our own
children not should be a single mom or
like nowadays the most important thing
that you see well let's think about that
common baby put him up for adoption
you see organizations that actually
target the devastation of datings with
illegitimate children and actually
there's a an organization in New Jersey
and it made me cry to hear the
commercial that actually if you have a
baby no questions as bring it to us do
not kill it do not throw it in the
garbage to die in the cold
give us the baby I'm not gonna ask you
any questions that is not a result of
Islam that is a result of being against
Islam and not following the rules of
Allah so panel that now to let us go
back in time a little bit yes because we
believe as Muslims once who have
submitted consciously to the one guy the
creator of all that exists that he
created us an original
goodness so if we look back to what some
other ways of life wasn't it that now
some of the ways of life they were
debating if the woman had a soul that
she is the the outcome is no sin and say
about that for example and and this is
not in the true teachings of problem
Hamas ISIL omits whether made
intentionally or through a Mis
translation in one of the early scribes
of Christianity they claim that it was
Eve that deceived Adam introduced
obeying God and listening to the devil
and by that all humanity after they were
supposed to be living in paradise now we
have to suffer here on earth
so the first send the original sin was
committed by Eve alone Adam to be
deceived you look at the Quran and this
is one of the Liberation's the
deliberation moments of women in Islam
fat as Allah how much light on one huh
it is the Shaitaan who deceived them
both into disobeying and lots of Hannah
talent out of paradise tell the dark
ages they were probably three to four
million women that were burned at the
stake why their bodies for reproduction
you know their sinful their dirty and
and all these kind of things what Islam
is teaching that not what any prophet of
God is teaching that's not the teachings
of Jesus peace be upon him that that's
not the tissues of anyone and and for
that every woman cooks well or she does
something out of the normal somebody's
just the easiest thing it just to burn
him at the stake you know they were
doing historically absolutely in the
matter of fact there's a tremendous
knowledge the herbal knowledge of the
women of the middle centuries on the
dark ages that would have benefit
humanity tremendously and that Herber
knowledge was burned to ashes with the
women that carried it and they were
burned at the stake
that was not Islam that was not even two
teachings of Jesus peace be upon him
that's the people that actually went
against women and once again it's the
law for loss of Hamilton so now we see
that Islam is truly liberating the woman
because Islam God Almighty he doesn't
blame the woman for this no first sin
does he absolutely not what is Islam
teach Islam teach that a man and a woman
get exactly the same reward
and many verses in the Koran you know
the people who are patient the people
who are righteous the people who are
praying that people are given charity
men or women men and women after each
description will get tremendous reward
from God when they do that a woman gets
exactly the same reward like a man and a
woman is a major part of society and you
know look at another honor that you know
Allah Subhan Allah bestowed upon women
who is the greatest woman of Islam ever
Virgin Mary the only holy scripture that
has virgin mary's name on it is in the
Quran that is his mother yes there's a
whole chapter named after her in that
battle God my own daughter's name is
Mariam yeah she's nothing like her but
at least we got the good name yes but
subhanAllah that's that's an honor
bestowed upon her to marry the greatest
woman that ever lived and will ever live
mine - this is amazing
absolutely so so you know that honor
there give you another example would you
know in America today allah subhanaw
taala had blessed me with four daughters
i can decide you know what i want to
give my money like let's say leona
helmsley the owner of huge real estate
in New York give her money to dogs not
to her grandchildren or children in
Islam that's totally forbidden
she has a guaranteed right of
inheritance and the woman in Islam in
hurts her father brother husband son
even if she's a great above a
grandmother she has the right if her son
or daughter passed away she would have
the right to inherit her branch Allah if
they passed away again she inherits from
everyone but only her money is for her
every male around her responsible
financial for her she shares their money
and she can in her stuff let's take a
break this is amazing some amazing facts
you're learning so much
sit tight to learn more she had often
miss translated as holy war the word
jihad means to struggle Islam does not
preach violence it does not preach
vicious holy war it certainly does not
condone terror and suicide bombing Islam
preaches compassion tolerance and
justice find the truth about Islam
call toll-free 877 why Islam or visit
why Islam org order your FREE copy of
the Quran today
back here on the Dean show with the
author of the lies about Muhammad Imam
Mustafa's aid and those are some more
lies that people try to deceive people
with some people unintentionally they
just don't know they just blindly
following what some other ignorant
people might be saying but now those
sincere open-minded hearted people are
coming to us to learn so they're
learning that Islam does not oppress the
woman but actually uplift sir
doesn't it absolutely tell us you
mentioned that she has a right to
inherit which she didn't have before yes
they were burning women they were
discussing with women had a soul these
were the other religions yes but Islam
said that as you said earlier that Islam
doesn't blame the woman for that first
sin committed this is original think
original totally wrong totally wrong yep
okay so we got that right to inherit
right to bear her own name wasn't it
something that now the husband would put
his last name on the woman because this
was like his property
why go far at the turn of the 20th
century exactly till 1882 in England the
beacon of our Western democracy a woman
could not stand up in court she was not
considered a legal entity and she could
not own property it has to be in the
name of her brother father or husband
she was not illegal until 1882 to 1880
1882 we're about to get into the 20th
century and that was in England
Elizabeth Blackwell the first physical
you know female physician in England and
in Europe for that matter the most
opposition that she got and resentment
she got from other females how could you
want to be in a profession that is
supposed to be a professional males
not only that they treated women that
horribly but the females themselves were
so brainwashed that they did not all
even know their own Worth and they
opposed her look at Islam mandated
education for women at the middle of
seventh century and a today they had
businesses they had ownership they have
the right to speak even women went to
promised acellam like almost the leaders
of opposition party no saber bent Aqaba
ansari was famous by umana and she
literally saved the life of the Prophet
one of the battles one man wanted to hit
him with a dagger and the battle she
threw herself on him and she received
the step in her own shoulder saving the
prophets wife she came to promise I said
I said o prophet of Allah all the verses
that are you know revealed from the
Quran so far are talking about men or
talking to men and I don't see anything
for women and because of that that was
the occasion and sort of as AB the
famous verse that you know the believing
women and the believing men and the
righteous women and righteous men and
and the praying women are pregnant all
gonna get equal rights and you know
these are the rights that Islam gave out
of the you know the first pledges that
the Muslim gave women gave pledges to
Prophet Muhammad SAW Allah and even and
you know scholars would tell you in the
science of narrating the hadith of
promise is Ln women readers of the
hadith and the leading one without issue
the probably the prophets wife are more
truthful than the average man and they
praised for that
yeah it's album called on Algeria what
daddy
so the honor of their and at the same
time look at how mothers are respected
Islam a man came to promise Allah said o
prophet who is most deserving of my
companionship he said your mother he
said all right we know that then whoa he
said your mother said oh right prophet
who then who is it your mother the man
out of desperation obviously said then
oh is it your father so look at them so
there are all mothers and the best thing
that Muslim can do is to pray to God on
time the second thing is to do well by
parents yeah and in the parents the
mother is sacred the mother is a woman
yeah and if you go to throughout the
Muslim world and see how mothers are
treated subhanAllah it's it's amazing
and so when people to come to say that
they're subjugated or that you know you
couldn't be further from the truth
so in Islam the the mother gets the gold
she gets the silver and the bronze and
the father gets the concept father gets
he gets they would have been around
amazing amazing so let's be fair because
somebody might have heard and said you
know what how is this when the
witnessing of a woman is one two two one
that's a very good or the in hair
tense this is only half that of a man
except excedrin these are very two
points let's take one after the other
the first one about the witnessing what
people do not understand is that
witnessing varies depending on the
situation
for example the verse of the Quran 282
that a lot of processes that bring two
men as witnesses and every that you have
only one man then replaced that missing
man by two women that's a business
transaction
that's for recording deaths and the
reason that a loss of half I in the
beginning made it two men witnesses not
one man witness not because one man is a
half a witness is for one man to remind
the other so when you replace that man
with two women why did you replace him
with one woman because you wanted the
two women independently remind each
other without having to interact with a
man that might be foreign to them and
that is one special situation for
example you go to a very important
significant event which is a husband
accusing his wife of cheating or vice
versa
a woman's testimony is exactly the same
testimony as a man she would testify
four times that he's cheating or he was
testify four times that she's cheating
and her testimony is equal to say in
crimes of murder if one woman is there
and she is credible like she did not
it's not known to be lying or you have
mental capacity issues her testimony is
enough to convict you know 10 min so it
varies so they go to these exceptions
and they make it the general rule that
is not true when it comes to inheritance
actually women get more than fair share
of inheritance for example the rule in
Islam who would inherit what it has
nothing to do with the gender the number
one rule is the position of the
generation is it a young generation that
needs more money to overcome the
obstacles of life or it's an old
generation they live their life already
meaning I have a mother and I have a
daughter and I pass away yes my daughter
would get half of the inheritance that
my son would have and I'll tell you the
reason layer but my daughter gets more
money than my own mother even though my
relationship with my mother is stronger
than my
I could marry you so many times and I
have 50 daughters but I have only one
mother my mother gets less than my
daughter
and they both females why because my
daughter is of the regeneration that is
a generation that is about to receive
life life so she gets more inheritance
the second thing is who is responsible
for whom it's not because she's a woman
or he is a man the reason is in Islamic
law the father is responsible for the
daughter then if he passes away her
brother then if if she's married then it
is the father then if he passes away is
the son they all responsible for her and
she inherits from all her inheritance
her own money is only for her if she
likes she can give to them if not it's
there it's only their money and they
still be responsible for her another
example I'm a woman that works you know
we have so many households in Islam that
the woman works and the husband works
the husband and wife both works her
money by Islamic law is all hers if she
wishes she can give her some or she can
support in the household and spend over
the children
he can't take her money he cannot take
care of his money she has rights and she
can put her hand in his wallet pocket
and take money if it justified he has to
spend over her and her children if she
wishes to give him from her income fine
if not he has no right to touch one
penny amazing it's starting to clear up
many of the absolute conceptions and fog
and tell us now why is it with all this
hype and misinformation more women is it
true are coming to Islam here in America
in UK all around the world in Europe
than men it's the world's fastest
growing religion Islam I have been given
a class for over five six years now for
new converts to Islam 90% of the
newcomers and people accept Islam are
females so if it's that subjugating and
that unfair and that intolerant of the
wrong position would somebody explain to
me that mystery that's a unless it's
totally the opposite of the truth
totally the opposite and as you see they
go to the severe exception
and mutilate it and make it the general
rule for example I you know every time I
speak to someone Oh women in Saudi
Arabia are not allowed to drive so let's
say the law in Saudi Arabia is very
protective of women and does not want
them to be exposed to be alone with a
man that they're not responsible for
there's 57 countries why you'll focus on
that one country for the one specific
thing and leave the other 56 countries
women are driving not a day they go to
rural areas in Afghanistan and Pakistan
and they're very hit with poverty
Afghanistan is the third poorest country
in the world and go in rural areas where
people are illiterate do not have you
know the the education or the knowledge
of Islam and only picture these people
as if these victims of poverty are you
know the whole Islam and the whole 1.6
billion population subhanAllah amazing
amazing we're we right back with more
here in the Deen show have you ever
wondered what Islam and Muslims are
truly about what do Muslims believe who
was Muhammad do Muslims believe that
Jesus will return is Islam respectful of
other beliefs what does the Quran say
about women would you like to learn the
truth about Islam would you like to read
the Quran for yourself find the answers
for yourself call toll-free 877 why
Islam or visit why Islam org back here
on the Deen show with Iman Mustafa's aid
we're talking about women in Islam and
clearly now people are getting the
opposite of what they've been told yes
Islam doesn't oppress the woman Islam
uplifts a woman and I think tell me what
you think that women are getting sick of
being used and abused you want to settle
a candy bar a Coca Cola Pepsi you got to
put this naked woman on there and
they're not being respected and I think
the smart women they're seeing this so
they see that Islam is uplifting me it's
protecting me it's not letting me be hot
and actually I answer that one of the
claims that Robert Spencer puts in his
book that will feel about allies about
Muhammad is that it says when Muslim
women are treated like commodities and
Muslim world and I had to answer excuse
me there's a multi-billion dollar
industry called the pornography industry
in America who you think is the victim
of that multi billion industry it's the
woman who would look at the AIDS of
infections women and men alike and look
at the ratios in Muslim country
statistically it's almost non-existent
in Muslim countries look at the divorce
rates and Muslim countries and some of
them are the poorest countries in the
world where divorce is more possible to
happen then and you cannot even compare
and what I even you know and I want to
tell our Muslim sisters who need to
answer to this who said that the Muslim
women are complaining did you ask the
Muslim women the woman that were in the
validity asked him or that someone hold
the gun to your head and ask you to put
this over your head in the morning or
you were it on your own love and
obedience to God and the way he uplifted
you and he respected you and your body
that it's not something a showcase for
for some materialistic thing
did you ask Muslim women no ask the
woman this is important those women need
to go talk to the women and ask them
tell us also before we come to an end
but they put someone on TV and she tells
her story she was born in a Muslim
household and now she wrote a book and
she's you know been given the microphone
and she says that you know Islam was
doing this and that to me it was
oppressing me and I had to run away and
this is Islam we gotta say and the
answer to that is where Islam is the law
the law of Islam is Quran and Sunna
please with your superior knowledge show
me that I am the Quran the verse in the
Quran or the correct hadith of the
Prophet that proves what are you saying
that it's not your dad committing a
crime against you but it's actually the
law itself in Quran and Sunnah and
you're gonna be wrong and most of these
people and I would willing to put that
challenge out there that they do not
even know how to recite one a of the
Quran or one crocosaur problem Hamas I
said that's why they are more interview
that someone like me now you're
available if CNN Fox News wants you to
come on are you willing to come on any
time because in a topical in Islam and
don't even give me five minutes for
preparation I'll go as is now how can
people get a hold of you if they needed
to my email is the lies about Mohammed
at gmail.com you can go to the web
side of the lies about Mohammed calm and
my information also in the book itself
so much to talk about you have your own
section at the Dean show calm we've
covered many topics there so I really
recommend people can get the book the
lies about Mohammed who is the last and
final messenger sent to mankind closing
comments and advice for the sincere
person out there who you know what he's
like or she's like you know Aslam is
making sense what do you got to say to
him well Islam is making sense is
probably the most common thread of all
the brothers and sisters that accepted
Islam they all come to me and some of
them are mostly highly educated
everything about Islam makes sense why
because it's the law of allah subhanaw
taala bringing you the best in life and
the best guidance and because he created
you he created the manual by which you
live your life and of course everything
would make sense that's all thank you
very much as a collage we are connecting
light and again again I just have to
thank you thank you so much for coming
to learn about Islam from us from the
Muslims thank you so much and I'm sure
you got the benefit and you've got to
learn that Islam does not oppress the
woman it uplifts the woman she's sick of
being used and abused for her body Islam
makes that woman someone who you respect
for her mind someone who you respect not
using abuse those most precious thing to
us we protect those things but the
Muslim woman is more valuable than any
car any commodity any diamond any of
these things they're our mothers our
sisters these are the most precious
things to us and you've gotten to learn
how much and how important the Muslim
woman and her role in Islam oh it's
amazing it's amazing and don't forget to
interact if you're a woman and you
really like what Islam has to say go and
talk to the woman the woman that you've
seen wearing the hijab ask her she
oppressed or she liberated ask her how
she feels
don't ask Fox News or CNN come to the
Deen show also so you can learn more and
we'll see you next time until then peace
be unto you